for the audience that doesn't know maybe
they only know you from call of duty
maybe they've seen a couple of uh
interviews stories that you down where
whether it's with the knife whether it's
how to handle the gun whether it's how
to handle a weapon
which is your specialty once you take a
a few minutes and share with us your
story your background how you went from
where you were at at the age of 2 3 when
you you your brother your mom the whole
story to come into the states
share your story a little bit with the
audience yeah thank you patrick i mean
it's it's through the struggles that we
find our strength and that's that's
that's truly what my life is about i was
born in vietnam i was born on a cold
cement floor
in the basement saigon hospital my
mother shielded my body from incoming
authority fire in my mourning my birth
at this stage of the war you know
american troops uh had left vietnam and
uh this left a devastating impact on
people itself and i was born on the
losing side of war
mid mid-70s when is this i was born in
74 74 yeah so american troops already
left vietnam 75 it was when saigon
failed vietnam um you know everybody
always talks about you know vietnam
reminds them of afghanistan you know
everything that's going on and and truly
that's what it was guys because uh we
were oppressed we were
my uncles that served alongside
americans they were in prison they were
uh brought out to the reeducation camps
these were labor camps torture camps
when when i received my uncle in the
states
he was in prison for 15 years when i
received him in the states he had no
skin on the bottom of his foot they
skinned the bottom of his foot they
broke him as a human being
as an individual i mean literally he
laid in the corner uh of the room he
wouldn't even lay in bed because he was
that uh traumatically uh traumatized
um at three years old we escaped on a
wooden fishing boat you know this this
boat probably fits about 45 people that
night
that morning that we escaped we were
fitting over 100 people in that boat and
guys we the the the trip was to come out
of vietnam and into
malaysia
right so two-day trip that was rough on
this fishing boat
on this fishing boat right so we had to
sleep on the bottom deck my i was a
little child three years old but we had
to sleep sitting up so think about like
you don't even feel your limbs anymore
your legs right because everybody's just
overstuffed so
uh the pie tree was going on during that
time so a lot of bandits pirates robbers
from surrounding countries it was a
lucrative business for them to stop the
boats
uh killing the men raped the women and
tortured the children it was common
practice amongst the fleeing refugees to
carry poison within their belongings and
the refugees would poison their children
if if they trip in for us as opposed to
subjecting like a life of slavery life
of slavery uh human trafficking uh
torture
uh the bandits were known to to torture
the children um
we've seen just the thought about
thought of that as just you know parents
carrying poison to prevent their kids
from going through that level of
struggle right i mean that's just trauma
at this highest level please continue so
we we
navigated out of vietnam
my mother said he was a um
a navy captain so he knew the tactics
you know and how to get uh past the
pirates basically shut off the engines
quiet down the motor and he uh he
x-filled out there uh at night you know
undercover darkness we went into the
shores of malaysia and and this time the
malaysian coast guard they shot at us
they stopped us
no more refugees in their country you
know um
so basically they they hooked and
anchors back on with a line they
forcefully drug us back out into the
south china sea
uh shot her motor cut the line and left
us there to die now what i want what i
want to say is guys we it was a two day
planned trip
so there was hardly any water there was
hardly any supplies it was hardly any
food we didn't plan that
so what i'm saying is now we're stranded
now this is a desperate survival
situation in the middle of the south
china sea you know so people are dying
um my mother said that we we drifted
roughly a month
we're out to see so people are dying
people are getting thrown overseas
people are getting sick
and my mother she she's contemplating on
that poison
because you're three years old at this
time i was three and are you is are
there other family members of yours with
you my brother my brother my biological
father and my mother and you brought
you're three he's seven right if i
recall your
brother you're a baby i mean like the
seven-year-old at least kind of knows
what's going on you've got no clue
what's going on i assume right yeah you
know i study the mind later on in life
that means i i study how the mind works
and you know if you suffer from
something so traumatic and if you can
really uh slow down the analytical
mindset and get into your subconscious
you know i do have visions
of that
trip
you know it's small little splashes but
long story short we're drifting out of
the ocean people were dying people were
getting sick but
we were drinking urine i mean it was it
was a desperate survival situation and
my mother said that she can't play on
the poison that she woke us up one night
and she contemplated his poison and we
had ulcers growing on her legs i mean
there's no
blood circulation in our legs think
about how overstuffed that boat was you
know malnourished and my mother gave us
everything she had the water she had the
food she had but now she was down to her
last bucket of water
and um
she contemplated this poison
she said later on you know she woke my
brother up and made him drink half of
the bucket of water and she made me
drink
and then she cried she couldn't do it
she couldn't kill us
you know so um
it was a miracle that's transpired at
night because um
that's the night that we got caught up
in a storm
a huge tropical storm think about like
the south china sea patrick right huge
tropical a fishing boat
these waves could easily
tip this over crazy can you pull up the
south china sea for a location reference
yeah so it's it's it's crazy just to
think about it and and this storm this
storm
saved us
see it it washed us
into
the lat long coronations of this route
where a russian supply boat was exiting
out of it now if that's not a god story
i'm going to tell you that's a god story
man
the south china sea is a huge ocean
and we were drugged
back out into the south china sea
and then somehow through the coordinates
of a lat long
a
russian supply boat intercepted us and
that right there is a million and one
changes that's the type of thing that
happens in a movie and you're like no
way that what's the chances that a ship
intersects them yeah that's
and somehow if you guys had gone to
cambodia it would have been even worse
for you so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]